so with respect to the seven planets
orbiting the star that was found by the
Trappist one program how cool is this
seven planets closer to their ultra-cool
dwarf star then our planet Mercury is to
our Sun and yet three of them apparently
I have a surface temperature suitable
suited to liquid water which immediately
makes one wonder could there be living
things there and that would get to the
deep question are we alone in the
universe
so the Trappist one investigation which
is done as part of NASA science which is
just not very much money in the big
scheme of things well make is making
these discoveries that will that have
the potential to change the course of
human history
I'm not kidding if we discovered life on
another world even one that remotely
distant it's 40 light years away it
would change everything we saw methane
in that atmosphere in the coming year
using the Spitzer Space Telescope and
the European Southern Observatory in
Chile they said they're going to do
their best to assay or figure out what's
going on with the atmospheres in the
coming year so the Spitzer Space
Telescope for example is just coolant to
keep it crazy cold
just a few kelvins above absolute zero
but it's run out of coolant but still
you're in deep space so it's pretty cold
anyway and so there they cost a warm
mission but it's not really that warm
and they're going to try to refocus or
properly focus and aim it to to ask to
assess what's in the atmospheres then
keep in mind the James Webb Space
Telescope is coming on we strongly
believe still on schedule 2018 which
isn't that far off and this is such an
intriguing solar system that you just
can't help but want to point telescopes
at it it would be extraordinary it'd
just be extraordin what if we saw
industrial gases and those at one of
those atmospheres would be amazing if
they have their own industry out there
then you point a radio telescope there
and listen and see if there's anybody
broadcasting games
or something on Trappist three or
whatever the heck it is so it's really a
cool thing and it said it is a fantastic
use of our intellect and treasure which
may lead to a discovery that is really
it's hard to even imagine the profundity
how significant it would be
[Music]